je vais vous faire une recette de piti
et fondant et donc je vais attaquer déjà
par mettre les poudres ensemble donc je
vais mettre le sucre avec les amandes je
vais mettre
la maïzena je mélange
gentiment mes poudres voilà et ensuite
les œufs
et là le beurre chaud
ou simple un peu comme un quatre-quart
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un petit bien
réussi c'est un Pithiviers qui va avoir
tout un équilibre au niveau de
l'épaisseur moi personnellement j'aime
pas avoir quelque chose trop épais parce
que bah plus vous le laissez au four
plus vous perdez en vous je trouve
il a l'air cuit pour vérifier on tapote
au milieu et on voit que ça s'enfonce
mais pas trop et on surtout on sent que
c'est pas liquide au milieu donc là il
est cuit il y a pas de problème et là on
va le démouler et hop toc et voilà on a
une belle petite coloration pas trop
prononcée mais juste ce qu'il faut et
puis maintenant on va préparer la glace
royale
sucre glace blanc d'oeuf et jus de
citron
j'ai appris on va dire sur le tas bien
sûr prendre de l'aisance aller glacer
c'est la finition et c'est ce qui est le
plus on va dire le plus le plus
compliqué pour bien recouvrir et bien
masquer le Pithiviers en entier la
décoration se fait essentiellement avec
des fruits confits nous ici en fait on
va faire simple on va faire juste
angélique bigarons l'angélique c'est un
végétal qui a été confidenti dans le
sucre et puis une fois confident le
sucre on coupe souvent des bâtonnets
voilà comme ça une fois que les
bâtonnets sont coupées on fait des
losanges
voilà et puis bigarreau c'est une cerise
tout simplement
là c'est le décor basique et mais le
plus efficace aussi du petit vieux
[Musique]
c'est un gâteau de voyage donc c'est
quelque chose qui reste moi le très
longtemps qui se conservent bien et donc
c'est onctuosité ce goût au bout
d'amande on a quelque chose de très
agréable à manger c'est un produit qui
est juste gras comme il faut et on a
quelque chose de très onctueux le
moelleux c'est ce qu'on recherche tout
simplement